uh I need moral support
oh
[Applause]
I feel only slightly better okay are we
ready are we ready for this is everybody
are we good
all right
the plan is to live as long as possible
yeah
I mean try your best
[Music]
my apologies if I don't talk I'm gonna
be concentrating foreign
level 30
um the level of Atlas is 45 so this is a
big difference in level here so this is
a very very difficult battle
oh
like whoa
abilities
and so yeah each of the the big attacks
have cooldowns so um you watch those
cooldowns and when you can use them
again use them again
oh
God oh
um
this Max guy is pretty good
oh you had to say something
awesome
so Final Fantasy 16 has a Parry system
so if you time your attack at the moment
that the enemy attacks you will get that
Perry and then you'll be able to deal uh
even more damage but it's very very
risky
oh nice
chance
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
take it down to uh
and it's down that the damage that you
deal while staggered is displayed at the
end of the Stagger
so next is uh doing very good at dodging
these attacks that's why I surviving for
so long that's a very good strategy is
[Laughter]
I say use his limit break
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Mommy
judgment bolts does a lot of damage in
this game so you want it when you want
to finish a battle quickly that's what
you use
[Music]
I'm sorry about the dog
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you can do this
oh my God
[Applause]
oh nice
I'd like to warn everyone I'm getting
close to having no healing
oh no oh nice oh
[Music]
it's got him on the ropes
God I see
Joseph so I I really tried there
[Music]
that losses I think 15 levels above
where we're currently at at this point
in the game but yeah I would I would
love to know if uh suzuki-san possibly
take can you show me a thing or two is
it is it possible we can get developers
to to at least I'd love to see how they
play it differently than me okay
[Applause]
[Music]
in Japanese
foreign
they had a a video where I did this
battle and um I lost
and uh so I think I want some Redemption
yeah
[Applause]
I say let's do this and
hi
okay let's turn on okay
all right yeah so somebody bring me a
beer I'm ready to uh
here we go
funny if he lost here too huh
sorry I'm gonna um refrain from speaking
now so
I'm really curious to see the
differences in play Styles like I was
going for an all-out
crazy damage
and I'm already seeing some nice
defensive stuff
foreign
I believe Titan has many physical
counters uh which is always fun in
action games when you can switch an
enemy's attack to being something that's
beneficial for you yeah
nice
[Music]
foreign
and so what you saw there is he uses the
Phoenix uh ability heat wave to cancel
out the magic and then counter with
three attacks
so yeah that was the counter as well
we've got lots of counter type of
attacks um for this game as well just
like you said I'm already seeing several
things I had no idea existed yeah
I know
come on
I'm seeing the biggest difference in
game plan he's doing a lot of whale
damage to eventually get them on the
ground to do more damage right
[Applause]
tonight
so yeah when an enemy gets staggered
that's when you want to deal with most
damage because your damage goes up
you can see he's not saying he's very
very nervous right now
foreign
nice
I'd like to note how difficult this is
he's been working this creature and it's
at 50 health
[Applause]
y
words
and again it's that level difference
right there he's got that 15 levels also
he's only wearing level 30 gear so his
gear is going to be weaker as well
laughs
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
so when you get good that's stagger
damage
oh okay
I love when you have to internally keep
in mind all of your abilities and if
they're available when you eventually
stagger the enemy
um
foreign
there's lots of different ways maybe
even ways that we as the developers
haven't thought of yet so
much
[Music]
I see that attack and I'm getting
horrible flashbacks now
that was close
ah oh
man
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]